all right this progressive summit called
Netroots nation is underway in New
Orleans this weekend the speaker's list
is a who's who of leftist darlings
from the impeachment obsessed Tom Styer
to the 2020 wannabes Kamala Harris
Elizabeth Warren and Cory Booker and
while that big names light up the
marquee the lesser-known politicians are
the ones who really have the pulse on
the direction of the party delivering
their manifestos to adoring crowds
here's the mayor of Jackson Mississippi
we have made the declaration in Jackson
Mississippi that we intend to be the
most radical city on the planet we need
to be prepared to be as radical as the
circumstances dictate we should be ok as
radical as the circumstances dictate ok
I need a translator for that one I don't
even get that but at the age of Trump
let's face it we have seen what that all
can entail and here's the mayor of New
Orleans on what she hopes will happen
next
people need we need economic justice we
need criminal justice reform we need
health and environmental justice we need
racial equality because we understand
that no one matters if everyone doesn't
matter no one matters if everyone
doesn't matter I guess that's a double
negative
that means no one matters right oh my
gosh all diagram that later but the real
question is this why fight so hard to
whip up change for an economy that's
actually working for the people at every
level of the economy let's just take a
look at what we're talking about here
black Hispanic and
making a massive comeback and get this
manufacturing jobs are back oh how many
times did Barack Obama say that couldn't
happen it's the strongest manufacturing
job market in 20 years despite what all
those naysayers told us so what's the
bottom line there's a glaring disconnect
between the so called resistance and
just regular Americans who want to work
for a living and those people are
reveling in Trump's economic Renaissance
just listen to some of my radio callers
this week I work with a largest shipping
company in the world I'm an outside
sales rep for them and I'm up 40 60
percent this year I think everybody sees
a difference everywhere I go people talk
about it and I think it's real
my family has a construction business
and my husband's phone is ringing off
the hook he currently has seven houses
to build he's added employees and is
hoping to give them more benefits you
saw an uptick as soon as the election
went through because of the optimism
when you talk to other people in
business and people that are working
whether it's truck drivers or whoever in
our particular line of work they are
happy I'm 28 years old I just recently
started a fiberglass business I'm making
the money hand-over-fist people are
willing to spend their money because
they're not worried that they're gonna
be broke tomorrow
Wow it is gonna be awfully hard for the
left to convince happy Americans to
change course when they're actually now
on a winning track that Netroots
gathering tells us a lot though doesn't
it about the direction of the Democratic
Party there so far to the left they're
so far beyond all the bromides that they
lack serious policy ideas to challenge
the president successful record they've
become basically the party of perpetual
grievance and perpetual complaint but
how long will that actually play among
an electric that is so much more
prosperous and what I can gather so much
more optimistic than they've been in
years who's gonna want to change that
reverse that as for the net roots I
think they could use some water the
kool-aid that they've been drinking has
gone to their head and this
why I called them nut roots and that's
the angle